hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares or Spooky's jump-scare
mansion as it's now called because the
developer was threatened with legal
action because the name Spooky's House
of jump-scares was taken or was used
prior I have no idea but it just sucks
sorry developer but I'm gonna play
because there's been an update called
endless mode and it's Booey
how's it going well considering I've
never played this before I'll hit
continue and hope for the best
nope there's nothing there so in this
new up state of sesh there's apparently
five new monsters and various new things
as well I forget was it better to play
this was better to play on a gamepad was
it not I seem to recall that being a
thing that I did don't break everything
it Josh do you work ok then I'm just I'm
just on my own okay here we go
don't know what's gonna happen in the
new update but it's been a long time
since I played Spooky's House of
jump-scares so it's good to be back good
to know that this game is still
puttering along but once again this
could take a while so we're going to be
doing a lot of cuts until we get to the
new stuff so I'll be back in a bit wait
hang on is this the same note that was
there before so I'm writing notes down I
think that this is the correct thing to
do in this situation I was filming the
mansion for my urban exploration video
channel but I think I'm trapped and I
ran out of battery on the cameras hours
ago so I don't remember that being there
whoa guys new well that's a nice
relaxing bed thanks for that I don't
know if that's gonna help me though hmm
well that was bizarre so is that that
seems do you think I would have
remembered something like that this is
new too there's a lot more bedrooms whoa
okay a little bit a new slightly
different box room although I don't even
remember the
in Roma boxes like who okay
I [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] I didn't know
holy [ __ ] bags oh my god is it after me
holy [ __ ] dag I don't know what [ __ ] dag
mean but man holy [ __ ] I was not ready
oh my god
so I'm guessing endless mode is supposed
to be just to survive as long as you can
but I didn't know if that meant it was
gonna be difficult though it looks like
it's gonna be bad I can't see a goddamn
thing
oh where am i oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ] ah
okay we're fine
get back don't get up before that er day
I don't know what that means
okay well [ __ ] I died well endless Mon
your soul Wiggles in agony
well I'm wiggling in agony right now and
ever damn on life a wiggly [ __ ] so that
was hard okay let me go at it again
trying it again so once again we'll only
pop up when we see something new a man
that was so dark I I literally couldn't
see where I was going in that one very
tourney room which with the beds the
backyard some of these rooms randomly
generated hello okay so that's another
note that's the same one as before and
hopefully I can find more notes to get
an idea of who that guy is and why he's
oh go away
are you new I remember seeing you all
right bye
[ __ ] hell jeez ins hi who are you are
you one of the jump skiers okay bye then
alright
oh whoa whoa whoa what a lovely painting
this is and terrifying oh hey you're
nice okay this place is fun this blazes
one [ __ ] off I know you [ __ ] off what
the [ __ ] is happening
I brought the [ __ ] am i dying
whoa okay all right okay all right I'm
leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm
leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving I don't
know why this is happening
it's one of the new specimens I can only
imagine good god this is so weird
and I love it I just wish I knew what
was happening yeah
all right man hope there aren't any
notes around here because I don't think
I'll be able to read them
oh boy am I going down a dead-end yeah
okay good golly this is awesome there's
a lot of new stuff here
and I bet they're gonna be mixing and
matching whoo okay but they're gonna be
mixing and matching a lot of the
monsters and I believed wasn't this
monster part of Cara Mari Hospital I
seem to remember like the iron bars
being everywhere around me but I'm not
on everson sure I went the wrong way the
wrong way okay oh please tell me I'm
gonna get out of this soon this is gonna
be like chaining monsters on me never
ending oh boy probably okay we're out of
the thick of it and we made it all right
that's good so we made it farther than
last time and I don't know how difficult
this game is gonna be no no there let's
try to get a high score shall we
let's do that oh nice
hey readers so everything is okay so far
I can't go back because these elevators
only go down but they have to stop
somewhere right
I've got enough food for a while and my
wind-up flashlight is working nicely Sol
see how this goes oh oh you silly [ __ ]
oh how little you actually know save and
down all right so we're gonna keep going
for a bit I don't know how much longer
I'm gonna try to do this one but it
seems like you can't continue an endless
mode adventure so if I get enough I'll
come back to it at another day I want to
see those new ones it's gonna be
squeezed okay
BRB okay why why why why why what what
why noise is something after me again
noise I noticed that you can't exactly
pull a fast one on me I'm right here and
I'm hearing it [ __ ] off to do list any
thing to do I've done all my chores one
criticize again with the weird baby pig
thing man manbearpig no boy no hahaha
what the fack what was that
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man good god I
know anything was after me I mean I
assumed with the weird pig squeals my
gosh stop it I didn't even stop to see
what you were because I got a thing
behind me apparently back goddamn it
I got caught up on a pool a slime
nothing needs to be stopping me now
don't stop me now I'm having a good time
I'm having a good time don't stop me now
I think it's gone I don't hear the
squeals anymore does it
I can only assume what the [ __ ]
goddammit it's got me boxed in what that
was so unfair oh that was so unfair that
was so unfair what a load of ass oh my
god that is so [ __ ] Oh such bull
bull shut such blows shut goddammit it
boxed me in like right there how fair is
that not at all I agree what a bunch of
dick attorney spooky sandcastle of land
shirts what's up what okay
I've no continue God eat it rude and so
angry I am
rage burps since when does music play in
this game well I bet I've been playing a
while and I'm pretty sure there hasn't
been any music like that plane before I
mean maybe it's just to occupy me while
I'm whoa day one I've entered a spooky
ghost mansion I do not know how long I
will be here but I hope not too long
well that's pretty much the the crux of
what everyone has to say when they're in
this place so I've got a new person
story that's different than the other
story that we were following don't know
why or how and I don't know why the
music's playing but it's awfully
Pleasant I like it a lot
welp music stop never mind it was
Pleasant for that juncture of time and
then no more yay okay we made it back to
room 50 which means that we're gonna
make progress day 2 today a so quite a
spook I'll admit it was scary but not as
scary as I've seen in some horror games
well that's good what will you offer how
about my soul
okay I'm gonna keep going and I'm gonna
see one more thing I'm gonna try to get
to room 100 and then I can end the
episode but if I die again
then I'm terrible and everyone can have
my youtube channel I'll retire and never
make a let's play again the stakes are
high whoa okay Wow whoo whoo okay Vicky
whoo oh [ __ ] off
it's upside-down land that's I've never
seen that before
it's not upside down here but oh oh okay
well this is new okay I guess we're done
with the upside-down land good I don't
know if I could have taken it oh oh oh
oh well doesn't sound good
that sounds new and fresh and exciting
okay I can only assume I'm being haunted
by a demon
Oh key I don't know what to do now this
is a new one definitely I've never heard
anything like this before
hmm oh man for some reason that noise is
just setting me on edge like a that
noises is really disconcerting made my
skin crawl for some reason taps into
something primal okay but we're making
good progress so I'll be back
how'd I do that I'm back right now
apparently oh the goop I forgot about
the goop okay I know about goopy goop
okay I know about goopy man kind of like
radical Airy but not quite right when
there's no floor you can't goop me all I
got to do is avoid the void the floor
entirely and I'll be good can you put me
back on the ceiling please I only have a
few more levels to go and I can only
assume that I'm about to be dict over
goddamn goop oh [ __ ] okay fine thunk
thunk the very funky I know I know I
know it's gonna be very funky all the
way to the finish line
yeah goop okay yeah a little more over
there oh thank you thank you for the
short rooms oh I had to say something
there we go
BAM in level 100 okay so day three I'm
beginning to get hungry and thirsty I
did bring much food other than my cheesy
curds I hope I will find more food soon
oh no you won't but you are food for
other things so that is the end of this
episode of Spooky's jump-scare mansion
whatever it's called now Spooky's House
of jump-scares it'll always be Spooky's
House of jump-scares in my heart or
spooky sand castle if land sharks is
also an acceptable name so thank you
everybody so much for watching and I'll
get back to this and even more exciting
jump scares very soon so thanks again
and as always LC
in the next video bye Mesa's man my case
well put the caps in there don't wanna
move everybody in the common radio
genius Diana how amazingly I just